ma de tôle grise c'était le plus grand
centre commercial de la ville dans les
décombres ces tee shirts et chemises sur
leurs cintres comme suspendu dans le
désastre on distingue les caisses du
supermarché
et sur le parking les caddies quasi
intactes apprécient
daria tenait la bijouterie elle tremble
encore ce matin elle a échappé de peu
aux deux missiles qui ont frappé
il ya eu la sirène l'alerté rien alors
on s'est mis à courir vers la sortie
arrière et puis trois minutes plus tard
il ya une explosion en avait du verre
parti dont les cheveux sur nos vêtements
y avait aussi de la fumée les gens
couraient c'était effrayant
combien de clients ont-ils pu s'échapper
il y avait selon kiev jusqu'à un millier
de personnes dans le centre
ce matin voici les restes d'une piscine
exposée pour la presse il faisait 11
mètres de long et plus de 5 tonnes toute
la nuit les sauveteurs ont travaillé
pour dégager les débris et retrouver les
courts c'est de la barbarie retrouver ce
sont des meurtriers
je n'ai pas de mots
le centre commercial est et il visait où
est ce une erreur de tir il est adossé à
une immense usine ici en bleu sur la
carte une usine qui a servi à l'effort
de guerre en 2014 des munitions étaient
tels stocker hier réponse du ministre de
l'intérieur ukrainien
non il n'y avait rien militairement
usées non
les sirènes viennent de retentir les
secouristes qui étaient sur le chantier
sont donc sortis alors selon moscou et
dian ce n'est pas ce centre commercial
qui était visé mais un stock de
munitions à proximité et les magasins
auraient simplement pris feu mais moscou
affirme aussi et là nous pouvons le
contredire que le centre commercial ne
fonctionnait pas au moment de
l'explosion
à